bonsoir à tous pour rebondir sur le talk
d'avant 1
j'ai une petite question c'est est-ce qu
enchaîner les relations les unes après
les autres
c'est grave c'est la question que pose
and mes meilleurs amis il ya quelques
jours après être sorti d'une très longue
relation et enchaîné les aventures et il
avait l'air super perturbé par tout ça
alors on s'est assis et on en a discuté
et c'est vrai qu'on le voit aujourd'hui
les relations dur - c'est devenu
tellement simple de trouver quelqu'un en
se répand sur son téléphone et en fait
quand on y réfléchit tout durement les
relations les expériences
professionnelles les objets on connaît
bien la phrase d'ailleurs on l'a tous
dit ah c'était mieux avant on a même
fait des mimes sur le nokia 33 10 et
l'iphone
c'était mieux avant aujourd'hui tout a
changé
on est passé des relations d'une vie aux
relations d'une nuit des batteries qui
dure 10 jours aux batteries qui dure 10
heures on est passé du durable au
jetable et qui perd le plus dans tout ça
notre bonne vieille planète acheter je
t'ai racheter et s'il y avait un
problème
50 millions de tonnes chaque année 50
millions de tonnes de déchets
électroniques viennent s'accumuler dans
un coin du monde où la main d'oeuvre est
pas cher et les législations peu
regardante 50 millions tonnes c'est
énorme c'est tellement gros qu'on voit
pas ce que c'est en fait 50 millions de
tonnes c'est l'équivalent du poids de
7000 tours eiffel ou de tous les avions
de ligne qui ont jamais été construits
par l'homme
en terme de taille c'est l'équivalent de
la taille de 90 pyramide de khéops
regardez la taille de la pyramide
regardez la taille de la ville derrière
mettez en 90 tous les ans 50 millions de
tonnes c'est comme si chaque minute un
auditorium comme celui ci était remplie
de déchets électroniques chaque minute
et sur ces 50 millions de tonnes
seulement une infime partie sera
recyclée pour se retrouver dans le
dernier appareil que vous allez acheter
au rabais utilisée trois fois avant de
le jeter et qui finira par venir
s'accumuler sur une 91e pyramide des
défis acheter je t'ai racheter comment
est-ce qu'on en est arrivé à un tel non
sens au final laissez moi vous raconter
une histoire
1929 le monde en dans la grande
dépression la plus grande crise
économique du 20e siècle
le chômage explose l'économie mondiale
ralentit ça contribuera même à la montée
du nazisme et par extension à la seconde
guerre mondiale et pendant ce temps là
un groupe d'industriels discute imaginez
la scène ils sont dans un bureau il fait
sombre les cigares fume on en 1929 les
voix monte c'est le fit bus car tel un
groupement d'industriels philips general
elektriks et plein d'autres en temps
normal ils se détestent mais aujourd'hui
ils se réunissent pour faire face à un
ennemi commun
et cet ennemi
le voilà il n'y a pas l'air méchant mais
cette ampoule
c'est l'image même de la durabilité
c'est le gros problème elle dure depuis
120 ans ça fait cent vingt ans qu'elle
brille dans cette caserne de pompier aux
etats unis
et ça c'est un gros problème en poule
incassable - ampoules vendues moins de
chiffre d'affaires vous voyez où je veux
en venir reprendre l'histoire
l'horloge tourne les bouteilles se
vident les cigares se succèdent et puis
soudain un consensus dorénavant toutes
les ampoules seront limités à une durée
de vie de miller profite aux biches au
dépit des consommateurs c'est la
naissance de ce qu'on appelle
l'obsolescence programmée
le principe il est très simple faire en
sorte qu'un objet casse plus vite afin
que le consommateur achète et très vite
cette pratique sera adopté massivement
dans tous les secteurs de l'industrie et
le problème de cette obsolescence
c'est qu'on la voit partout on se
demande jusqu'où est ce que ça va à
guise d'exemple dans les années 60
mesdames ce que vous saviez que vos
collants était assez solide pour tirer
une voiture aujourd'hui j'en ai parlé
juste avant de faire sauter talk avec
une amie en disant que je voulais tester
elle m'a dit mais moi mais que l'on juge
me baisse et casse du coup j'ai testé ça
fonctionne pas essayez pas
relation électroménager prêt à porter
c'est comme si tout était désormais fait
pour ne pas durer et les consommateurs
dans tout ça faisons un saut dans le
temps cette fournée en 2003 à l'aube de
notre ère numérique digital comme disait
morgan facebook n'existe pas encore mais
cependant les témoignages d'utilisateurs
fusent il semblerait que les imprimantes
cesse d'imprimer alors que les
cartouches encore à moitié plein cette
fois ci on passe du bureau de nos
industriels avec leurs sicav etc et on
tombe dans celui d'un des ingénieurs du
magazine pour consommateurs which c'est
l'équivalent français de l'ufc que
choisir
l'odeur de pizza froide a remplacé
l'odeur de cigares des papiers des
canettes sont dispersés un peu partout
sur le bureau enfin bureau d'ingénieurs
corps et devant son écran notre
ingénieur yeux rougis par la fatigue
vient de faire une découverte
après des jours acharné de travail il
vient de reprogrammer la puce d'une
cartouche encre
il vient de démontrer que les cartouches
sont volontairement régler pour arrêté
d'imprimer après un certain nombre de
cycles afin de forcer les consommateurs
à acheter
et vous voyez le problème c'est que ce
problème d'imprimantes
on le voit partout dorénavant
l'obsolescence programmée est connu de
tous et cette découverte que fera ce
magazine elle va se disperser partout
dans le monde et les consommateurs ont
commencé à se poser la question jusqu'où
est ce que ça va dans quels objets et
scassa et on commence à se dire c'était
mieux avant ça dure - aujourd'hui c'est
le cas et aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il en
est voilà des dizaines d'années que
l'ampleur de ce phénomène grandi
cependant de l'an poule à l'iphone
l'obsolescence programmée a bien évolué
l'obsolescence telle qu'on la connaît
c'est à dire faire en sorte qu'un objet
casse afin que le consommateur achète
finalement c'est devenu relativement
minoritaires
aujourd'hui l'obsolescence c'est moins
faire en sorte que l'objectif mais
beaucoup plus faire en sorte que le
consommateur vous moi aient envie de le
remplacer et fonctionnel ou pas et c'est
là le problème
l'obsolescence programmée a donc laissé
place à de nouvelles formes
d'obsolescence
la première c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'obsolescence logiciel est là on l'a
tous vécu sur nos téléphones des
ordinateurs de consoles de jeux
problèmes de compatibilité des nouveaux
jeux et des nouveaux programmes
ralentissements intempestifs dès qu'on
fait une mise à jour vous dès qu'on la
fait pas d'air le calvaire la seconde
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'obsolescence de
support et là le problème il est un peu
plus détournés parce que c'est toute la
partie après vente qui est défaillante
complexité du processus après vente
indisponibilité des pièces de rechange
délais de réparation très long coût
exorbitant au final c'est comme si tout
était fait pour qu'on se dise finalement
c'est beaucoup plus simple de juste
racheté et la dernière probablement la
plus subtile c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'obsolescence psychologique et là on
parle de mode de saisonnalité de nouveau
design de nouvelles couleurs qui fait
que très vite on veut avoir le dernier
modèle la dernière version
l'ancien paraît juste d'un autre temps
d'ailleurs puisqu'on parle de mode
à titre d'exemple aujourd'hui on achète
60 % plus de vêtements qu'il ya 15 ans
mais on les garde deux fois moins
longtemps la durabilité la vie dure
résultat les consommateurs se sont
trompés les entreprises font plus de
bénéfices et l'obsolescence est devenu
un mal assumée 92% des français sont
d'ailleurs convaincus que les objets
électroniques et high tech sont
volontairement construit pour ne pas
durer 92 % sur les dix l'a9
ça fait beaucoup mais sommes nous
vraiment
les marionnettes de méchants industriels
assoiffés de profit ou est ce que cette
histoire d'obsolescence elle serait pas
un peu plus compliquée qu'elle en a
l'air reprenons notre histoire de
vêtements tout à l'heure on achète 60 %
plus de vêtements qu'il ya 15 ans tout
en les gardant deux fois moins longtemps
à roque est certes les vêtements du
roman aujourd'hui mais qui est prêt à
mettre le prix
si on regarde les chiffres de l'étude
omnibus 43% des français et 65 % des
18-24 ans déclare sa vie et dans les
enseignes face la chaîne zara h&m mango
et tous les autres pas vraiment connus
pour leurs records de durabilité et si
on interroge ces mêmes français 81%
déclare le prix comme étant le critère
d'achat principal dans la décision
contre seulement 27% pour la durée de
vie du produit
mais du coup a toujours cherché le
meilleur prix la dernière fonctionnalité
la nouvelle couleur nous consommateurs
sommes aussi responsables de tout ce
qu'on appelle obsolescence programmée et
qu'on aime bien remettre sur le dos des
autres parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
fonctionne dans un sens on a aussi tout
bénéficier de nombreux avantages de
l'obsolescence
premièrement la baisse des prix la
baisse des prix générale a permis au
foyer de s'équiper d'objets qui
autrefois était très onéreux télévision
électroménagers ordinateurs aujourd'hui
un réfrigérateur coûte en moyenne six
jours du salaire moyen d'un français
alors qu'il ya une trentaine d'années
sans coûter 14 sacs les réductions et en
même temps les cycles de vie beaucoup
plus court des produits ont permis de
simuler de façon incroyable l'innovation
donc beaucoup plus de nouvelles
technologies et de nouvelles
fonctionnalités et la concurrence donc
beaucoup plus de produits sur le marché
mais au final plus de produits plus de
nouvelles technologies meilleures
fonctionnalités ce qui rend les
consommateurs heureux c'est ça mais la
source de sa c'est aussi ce qui les
faisait se sentir trompé en premier lieu
on se rend compte que l'obsolescence
elle est un peu plus compliquée et
nuancée qu'elle en a l'air et une part
de l'arrêt l obsolescence de ce qu'on
considère obsolescence est directement
dus à nos modes de consommation et au
rythme d'innovation technologique
cependant la seule chose qu'on ne peut
pas nous lancer
c'est le mal fait à notre planète une
planète
on en a qu'une on en a parlé ce soir on
va le réentendre toute la soirée
probablement rappelez-vous 50 millions
de tonnes un auditorium par minute et ça
c'est les déchets électroniques on parle
pas des déchets plastique des emballages
de l'énergie utilisée pour la production
pour le transport pour l'extraction des
matières premières et j'en passe de ce
point de vue le bilan est plutôt
catastrophique
heureusement nous entrons dans une
nouvelle ère citons bien c'est le sujet
de ce soir lunaire où les mentalités
changent évoluent une ère où
l'environnement est au coeur des débats
une ère où chacun va avoir un impact et
heureusement des solutions il y en a il
suffit juste de les mettre en place
c'est pas les solutions les plus
innovantes les plus sexy mais elle
existe plus tôt on parlait de durabilité
de réparabilité et les initiatives dans
ce sens grandissent chaque jour partout
dans le monde on voit fleurir des
nouveaux lieux atypiques par exemple
vous pouvez apprendre à réparer vous
même vos objets du quotidien vélo
électroménager vêtements
tout y passe c'est ce qu'on appelle les
rippeurs café y en a plus de 2000 dans
le monde et en a même un à lyon et je
veux la dame qui fait comme ça
probablement qu'elle a déjà été
ou qu'elle connaît et en france ça va
même plus loin dès 2021
le degré de réparabilité des objets sera
affiché en magasin histoire de donner
aux consommateurs une base de
comparaison dit
ferrante que juste les fonctionnalités
et le prix et leur permettent de faire
des choix plus conscients et puisqu'on
parle de réparabilité certaines
entreprises font même de tout ce
phénomène leur coeur de métier c'est le
cas de fer phone par exemple qui
développe le tout premier smartphone
entièrement réparable par n'importe qui
chez lui à la maison
quelque chose casse on le commande on
peut le réparer c'est pas comme le
téléphone qu'on peut plus ouvrir parce
qu'il ya plus de vie se sont maintenant
est partout désormais envoyer des objets
de plus en plus modulaire les notions de
modularité et d'évolutivité commence à
envahir nos objets du quotidien
on voit apparaître des montres modulaire
des téléphones sur lesquels on peut
changer le module mettre un appareil
plus puissant un processeur plus
puissant davantage c'est que on peut
adapter son téléphone à soi et je peux
encore écho à morgane qui dans son talk
parler de la personnalisation
ça nous permet de personnaliser l'objet
mais ça permet surtout de remplacer des
pièces et de faire évoluer de faire en
sorte qu'un produit qu'on a acheté
puissent évoluer dans le temps et qu'on
n'est pas juste a jeté à la poubelle et
même des voitures qui deviennent
évolutive pense à tesla par exemple qui
a rendu ces voitures semi autonome grâce
à des mises à jour parce que les
voitures ont été anticipées dès la
création pour pouvoir évoluer toute la
partie hardware électronique a été créée
de sorte à ce que la voiture puisse
évoluer donc à la base elle n'était pas
semi autonome grâce à des mises à jour
logicielles
elle est désormais c'est tout le
principe de l'évolutivité de la
modularité c'est de rajouter des
fonctionnalités et faire en sorte que
quelque chose qui à la base d'aller
durée un an ou deux puisse durer
beaucoup plus longtemps une dimension
bien sûr qu'on connaît tous c'est la
recyclabilité
on le connaît tous on a vu les poubelles
avec le petit logo vert et encore une
fois la recyclabilité ça se base sur
l'anticipation anticiper l'après vie du
produit dès sa création
c'est la clé et on peut encore une fois
par les deux marques de véhicules
électriques il y en a plein qui anticipe
la seconde vie des batteries au lithium
c'est un élément compliqué c'est dur à
recycler alors dès que les batteries
pertes en efficacité
le client peut les renvoyer l'échangé
tandis que les anciennes pile qui sont
toujours fonctionnel et moins efficaces
sont utilisés pour du stockage
domestique par exemple
avant d'être finalement recyclé encore
une fois anticipé c'est la clé et c'est
un avantage économique pour le client
pour l'entreprise mais aussi pour la
planète parce que désormais les
ressources sont utilisées beaucoup plus
longtemps
et comme les mentalités les
comportements changent et laisse place à
de nouvelles façons de consommer leurs
droits c'est le cas du hardware race de
services ou de l'économie du partage par
exemple et tous les deux sont basés sur
un même principe très simple avoir
l'expérience d'un produit sans forcément
le détenir et ça tombe bien
toutes les études sur les nouvelles
générations montre qu'on est de plus en
plus portés sur l'expérience de quelque
chose est de moins en moins sur sa
possession
reprenons le cas du téléphone par
exemple parce qu'on en a tous c'est un
peu le prolongement de notre main on
soit addict ou pas on en a tous sens
urnes aujourd'hui
si vous voulez le tout dernier téléphone
de la marque
et puisque d'après et celui d'après et
encore celui d'après malgré tout ce
qu'on vient de dire aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on peut bien faire si on prend le
problème à l'envers
au lieu de payer 1000 et quelques euros
pour le tout dernier smartphone est ce
que vous pourriez pas payer quelques
dizaines d'euros par mois pour la gamme
platinum contenant le tout dernier
smartphone et à la sortie du nouveau et
vous suffirait juste de procéder à un
échange tandis que votre ancien
téléphone passe d'une gamme inférieure
seraient revalorisés ou donner à nos
clients ce mode de consommation ce
business model
c'est le hardware à ce service il ya
énormément d'entreprises qui commencent
à se poser dessus
hp apple en ce moment explore le appel à
ce service dans lequel pour une
trentaine d'euros vous auriez le tout
dernier iphone et puis pour une
cinquantaine d'euros vous aurez chaque
mois le tout d'ouvrir le fun avec d'une
assurance une apple tv n'appelle musique
etc
microsoft l'a déjà adopté avec ces
nouveaux ordinateurs les surfaces ce que
vous pouvez aussi avoir en hardware à ce
service et là on change la dynamique
parce que c'est l'entreprise qui reste
propriétaire du produit donc dans ce cas
là économiquement elle a tout intérêt à
faire en sorte que le produit dure le
plus longtemps possible puisqu'elle en
est propriétaire et le consommateur peut
faire des choix de changements beaucoup
plus durable une solution pour
l'entreprise et pour la planète mais
aussi pour le consommateur
et pour les produits qu'on utilise
beaucoup moins pourquoi ne pas réfléchir
au partage
pourquoi acheter une perceuse quand le
français moyen utilisé en moyenne sept
minutes par an et qui en a 10 dans la
même rue cloud et si on réfléchit même à
la voiture une voiture elle perd 10% dès
qu'elle touche le sol
on le sait mais elle est aussi gare et
95% du temps pourquoi payer des dizaines
de milliers d'euros pour quelque chose
qu'on utilise finalement 5 % du temps et
serait pas moyen de mutualiser tout ça
c'est le principe même de l'économie du
partage le principe mettre en commun les
ressources d'une personne la possession
d'une personne et la faire profiter à
d'autres gens ça permet à la personne
qui à cet objet d'avoir une autre source
de revenus mais ça permet surtout
d'éviter que 15 personnes achètent la
même chose qui va au final être obsolète
au bout d'un moment et de multiplier par
15 des déchets comme vous le voyez
toutes ces solutions elle existe c'est
pas les plus novatrices au monde
c'est pas les plus innovantes mais elle
existe et la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les initiatives allant dans ce sens
grandissent chaque jour et en préparant
state je regardais les têtes de l'an
dernier qui sont passés sur cette même
scène
hothead x lion est une skieuse parler
d'une phrase qui était génial estime
céline parce où elle disait pour que les
solutions dur il va falloir que chacun
d'entre nous déconstruisent ce qu'il
croit être vrai et dans un sens j'espère
que c'est ce qu'on a fait ensemble
aujourd'hui j'espère que vous avez
compris qu'on est tous responsables dans
cette nouvelle économie du prêt à jeter
mais qu'ensemble entreprises comme
consommateur on peut rendre
l'obsolescence obsolète
donc si demain vous allez à la fnac ou
je ne sais pas où acheter des objets
j'espère que il y aura quelques mots de
ce que je vous ai dit aujourd'hui qui
résonneront et que vous réfléchirez à la
durabilité à comment consommer
différemment et vous ferez des choix
plus conscients vous aussi merci
beaucoup à tous
on s'arrête
[Applaudissements]